there was a time when tarnished who had
strayed from guidance feared nothing
more than utter silence their deaths
were delivered by the confessors
Assassins dedicated to the teachings of
the two fingers who were sent from
churches outside the lands between the
two fingers preached the glory of the
greater will but inevitably some
worshippers strayed from their teachings
and lost the two fingers favor however
upon confessing their sins they learned
that they were still able to serve so it
was that they pursued their Duty in the
darkness that is without Grace learning
incantations of concealment and Shadow
the twin blade is their weapon of choice
as is crepus V crepus was their head
Confessor and famously wielded a black
crossbow that he fired from the shadows
of Round Table hold its black bolts are
tipped with Scarlet Rod spelling certain
death for any tarish that stray from
guidance as he once did so Grace has
returned to these confessors and it has
led them back to the lands between this
is why